[Música]
y ahora llegó el momento para hablar de
economía y para eso nos acompaña en
nuestros estudios en bogotá nuestro
periodista jorge hurtado jorge buenas
noches para usted y empecemos hablando
de los viajeros en europa que están
enfrentando retrasos en sus vuelos
porque bueno esto principalmente porque
la industria aeroportuaria todavía no
logra recuperar al personal que perdió
durante la pandemia del 19 en el año
2020 se suma ahora a que los pocos
trabajadores que hay decidieron irse a
huelga pidiendo mejores condiciones
salariales los principales aeropuertos
europeos van a seguir registrando estas
semanas retrasos y cancelaciones por la
falta de personal y también por las
huelgas de easyjet y ryanair en el reino
unido- las compañías aéreas atraviesan
una crisis debido a esta falta de
personal y los aeropuertos se están
viendo obligados a cancelar sus vuelos
por esta falta de capacidad en sus
instalaciones en los aeropuertos de
parís se bloquearon unas 35 mil maletas
la mayor parte de las cuales seguían sin
haber sido devueltas una semana después
según los datos recientes publicados por
peri la agencia de viajes 'online' cuyas
raíces se encuentran en la aviación y en
el big data estos son los 10 peores
aeropuertos en europa con mayores
retrasos o cancelaciones de vuelo una
situación que parece apenas empezar
marie clarie en eeuu también se registra
una situación bastante similar bueno y
usted a propósito que menciona eeuu
hablemos de un tema monetario porque hoy
el dólar alcanzó la paridad con el euro
una situación que no se veía desde el
2002 esta paridad se logró gracias a
varias situaciones combinadas que están
ocurriendo en la economía global ya esto
sucede por las subidas principalmente de
los tipos de interés que varios bancos
centrales en el mundo están haciendo
para controlar la inflación global la
guerra en ucrania también afectó al euro
esto por la cercanía y dependencia
energética y sobre todo los temores
generalizados de una recesión económica
el impacto más directo de esta
depreciación del euro es en los precios
cerca de la mitad de los productos
importados en la zona euro son
facturados en dólares frente a un 40 por
ciento que son comprados en euros esto
según datos de la oficina de
estadísticas eurostat
ahora se necesitan más euros para
comprar los productos importados en
dólares otro impacto maria clara será en
el turismo habrá un freno al turismo
europeo sobre todo hacia eeuu aunque los
turistas de eeuu y de otras naciones
podrían de cierta forma beneficiarse con
el tipo de cambio y pueden consumir más
con la misma cantidad de dólares ahora
los mercados sobre todo los inversores
están atentos a la siguiente reunión del
banco central europeo que se va a
realizar la próxima semana en donde se
va a definir si la subida de los tipos
de interés ahí la primera será de 25
puntos básicos además a propósito de
esta moneda el dólar está ganando fuerza
en chile y en colombia cuál es la
situación bueno el dólar se mantuvo en
chile- por encima de los 2 mil pesos y
alcanzó el máximo histórico mientras que
en colombia el dólar tuvo una nueva
jornada al alza y con precios históricos
superiores a los 4600 pesos por dólar es
la segunda moneda más depreciada del
mundo la colombiana tan sólo después del
rublo ruso en chile por ejemplo el banco
central anunció que no descarta tomar
medidas de contención por esta situación
las causas en ambos países
latinoamericanos es por contexto el
fortalecimiento global de la divisa
americana y también el retroceso del
valor del cobre la principal exportación
de ambos países debido en parte también
a las restricciones que china mantiene
en varias ciudades por los
confinamientos del cobi 19 y ahora
hablemos de un movimiento en los
negocios porque twitter demandó a hilo
más para forzarlo a comprar la empresa
pero la red social acusamos de violar el
acuerdo de 44 mil millones de dólares
para comprar comprar esta plataforma la
demanda da inicio a uno de los mayores
enfrentamientos legales en la historia
de world con la participación del mayor
millonario del mundo el viernes mos
canceló el acuerdo porque según el
twitter incumplió al no responder a las
peticiones de información sobre cuentas
falsas o de spam ahora la red social
acusamos de una larga lista de
violaciones del acuerdo de fusión que
han afectado según ellos el valor de la
compañía twitter dice que hemos usa un
pretexto y que su decisión tiene más que
ver con un descenso en el mercado de
valores en particular para las acciones
tecnológicas
gracias por toda esta información
económica y nosotros continuamos con más
noticias aquí en directo américa
[Música]